where OS by Google is based on Android
as a result the concepts and tools you
use for Android development are
applicable for wear with that being said
where OS is a different form factor
my name is Agha and I will walk you
through some key differences and
wearable and mobile development before
diving into the code it's important to
think about the user experience and
focus on a use case that makes sense on
a watch if you have an existing mobile
app choose a core functionality that
will work well on a watch
once you have nailed down the use case
designed for round screens first a round
screen has 22% less UI space than a
rectangular display so this will ensure
that your layout works on both round and
rectangular displays lastly take your
design for a spin where OS is designed
to be used on the move as such a UI
design that works well on a computer
monitor may not work in real life on a
watch test your design using at least
one where OS device great now you have
locked down the user flow and the design
what are the development tools available
to you well in addition to the regular
Android tools such as Android studio
we offer api's and support libraries to
make your life easier on the platform
forint wear wear supports the - round
and - not round identifiers for
resources as a result you can have
different layouts or drawables depending
on the screen shapes we find that round
and square layouts tends to be the same
so maybe two dimension files containing
different padding and margins are all
you need try it out in addition we have
added a number of UI components that are
round aware in the wear UI library for
example the wearable recycler view
around a wear recycler view the box
inside layout which keeps all the
contents in the centre square of a
circle and the swipe dismiss frame
layout a UI pattern on wear was for
dismissing views in addition to round
designs
we're what supports always own apps that
have longer user sessions by default
when the user is not using your app
where was dismisses it and returns to
the watch face well this works well for
apps with a short user flow it works
less well when you are trying to check
items off while shopping in the local
market
other examples include exercise or
travel apps that's why we created the
always-on feature with always own apps
when the user is not using your app the
watch will go into ambient mode turning
off the processor but keeping your app
in the foreground this reduces battery
use while making a presume fast and
fluid well your app is in ambient mode
you can update it once a minute
providing useful updates to the user to
implement this your activity will need
to implement ambient mode support dot
ambient callback provider and tell where
was how it should render the screen
while in ambient mode where always by
Google you're developing on top of a
fully featured operating system would
access to GPU and sensors if you have an
existing mobile app consider which key
user flows make sense for where Wes
which actions will be better on the
wrist and on the phone so what will you
make
[Music]